marie verrückt ist es eigentlich dass
wir menschen in unserem körper einen
ganzen neuen menschen heranzüchten ich
weiß nicht wie viele schwangerschaften
ihr in eurem umfeld so mitbekommen habt
ich durfte es zuletzt bei unserer meile
grafikerin melanie beobachten dem treuen
mai lag oder schön schlau zuschauer ist
wahrscheinlich aufgefallen dass meine
videos letztes jahr irgendwann nicht
mehr animiert waren das lag daran dass
melanie in elternzeit war aber melanie
esbeck und zu diesem anlass haben wir
eine wissenschaftliche dankesrede an die
mutterschaft erstmal danke an alle
organe die sich während der
schwangerschaft einfach zur seite
schieben lassen während das baby die
ganze bauchhöhle für sich beansprucht
danke an die bauchhaut die sich
freundlicherweise für das baby um ein
vielfaches denen lässt dank an unseren
ihren die müll filter unseres körpers
denn nicht nur dafür sorgen dass der
eigenen öl ausgeschieden wird sondern
auch der des anderen kleinen menschen
der da heranwächst um den müll
loszuwerden wird mehr urin produziert
was in kombination mit dem druck eines
kleinen menschen auf die blase dafür
sorgt dass die toilette der neue beste
freund einer jeden schwangeren wird
damit auch danke an den status unserer
sanitären anlagen und abwassersysteme
mit denen wir in deutschland gesehen
sind dann kehren die brustdrüsen die
perfekte mix aus proteinen
kohlenhydraten zucker aus der blutbahn
aufsammeln und zunächst zusammen bank so
perfekt dass das baby die ersten sechs
monate oder manchmal auch länger gar
nichts anderes braucht danke an den
mütterlichen geruch sind der während der
schwangerschaft erstaunlich
sensibilisiert und ja was bringt das
eigentlich mit ein grund für die
morgenübelkeit während der
schwangerschaft sehr doof ist naja
vielleicht ist ja doch für irgendwas gut
der grund für die schwangeren supernase
hier derzeit noch weiter erforscht
danke an das mutterherz dass während der
schwangerschaft bis zu 40 prozent mehr
blut pumpen muss
danke an oxytocin das kuschelhormon dass
sowohl bei mamas als auch bei papas für
bonding mit dem baby sorgt sondern die
hersteller auch danke an das testosteron
dass sich freundlicher höflicher weise
bei vätern zurückzieht damit die sich
besser um ihren nachwuchs kümmern und
ich glaube melanie hat auch noch was zu
sagen ich möchte danke sagen an den
einzigartigen hormoncocktail der uns
mamas wer hinter geburt superkräfte
verleiht danke an die wirbelkörper wie
das baby trägt sondern monatelang danke
körper dass du mein baby neun monate ein
großartiges zu hause war ganz wichtig
danke an die anderen mamis sache dass
sie einem das gefühl geben nicht alleine
zu sein mit gedanken wie bin ich eine
schlechte mutter
ich mache alles falsch reicht meine
milch auch um etwa eine million anderer
fragen oder gedanken die man sich machen
es hilft einfach sehr wenn man weiß dass
man nicht die einzige ist die vor
erschöpfung auch mal weint ich ziehe den
hut vor allem bekannt
und trotz aller strapazen ist es einfach
nur wundervoll mama zu sein
von so einem wundervollen baby dieses
glück selbst ein auch nach der
hundertsten nicht durchgeschlagen nacht
nur funktionieren das war unsere
unvollständige dankes liste für was seid
ihr dankbar und für was vielleicht auch
nicht schreibe es in die kommentare
teil dieses video gerne mit euren
lieblings müttern wir sehen uns nächsten
donnerstag bis dahin sicher wir kommen
in der end card werbung für alle die es
verpasst haben mailand wurde für den
grimme online award dieses jahr
nominiert war und ihr könnt für den
publikumspreis abstimmen
der link ist in der video beschreibung
ihr müsst ihr auf das mädchen darauf
klicken dann ganz unten auf der seite
noch euren namen usw eintragen jeder hat
drei stimmen sind noch viele tolle
andere formate nominiert ihr könnt also
auch verschiedene stimmen vergeben aber
wenn die sehr harte freunde der sonne
seit typ ich natürlich auch alle drei
stimmen an mileys begeben danke euch bis
nächste woche